hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
round 3 of our coverage of the 2018 a
Tata Steel tournament and we have a good
one today one of the best chess games
I've seen in a while excited to bring it
to you today white is played by fan
favorite vision on always bring his
AGame to these big tournaments and his
opponent number two player in the world
and that is Fabiana Caruana we'll get
started with Vichy he starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 and Fabiano
does the same thing he did in round one
against Magnus Carlsen he plays the
petrov Knight to f6 so this leads me to
believe that
Fabiano wasn't just playing games in
round one this is the big preparation
that he has for this tournament he
thought he would see a lot of pawn to e4
and so he's done a lot of preparation
for the petrov defense we started out
the same as we saw in round one and that
is the knight taking here on e5 pawn to
d6 that is going to kick the knight back
definitely a better move to play pawn to
d6 than any other variation if you're
gonna play Knight takes here on e4 any
of that definitely better to just kick
it back here and then you can continue
however you want to Knight takes down on
e4 in unlike Magnus Carlsen who played
Queen to e2 this she decides to go with
the main line and that is to ignore this
Knight here for right now and play pawn
to d4 pawn to d5 adding support to the
night here on e4 Bishop up here to d3
getting ready to castle on the kingside
the board also attacking this Knights in
at the stern of the board kind of a
pesky night here on e4 that White's
gonna have to worry about for sometime
Bishop down here to a d6 also opening up
for a king side castle and then castle
on the King side at many times what
White's gonna be looking to do is play
pawn to c4 to disrupt this pawn here on
a d5 which is supporting the Knights and
then play rook over here to e1 really
trying to aim a lot of his material here
on at the knight on e4 black castles on
the King side and then pawn to c4
Fabiano
well prepared for this pawn to c6 both
sides playing their moves in just a few
seconds you can tell both sides prepared
for this opening especially being the
main line they've seen it many many
times in Fabiano I can imagine he's seen
all of these since this is his favorite
opening so far of the tournament only in
round 3 so we see continued play Queens
who a situ just adding additional
support attacking the square here on e4
seems like the entire game right now is
centered around that knight on e4 Knight
to a6 getting ready to come down to B
for threatening both the Queen and the
bishop
that is a critical square so as you can
imagine a white immediately plays pawn
to a3 to stop that now all of a sudden
you have the knight here on a six not
really doing too much so you'll see that
Knights look to get to a better Square
right now it's just kind of hanging out
waiting to see what white does the
Bishop's gonna come down here to g4 just
getting that Bishop involved into the
game black has now completed development
white does have a few things that he
needs to do he needs to get his dark
square Bishop involvement of the game
but doesn't have too many great options
right here normally he would be putting
down a knight with Bishop here to g5 but
he does not have that luxury right now
doesn't right now I want to play Knight
to c3 doesn't want to block his Bishop
off by playing Knight to d2 so instead
continues with Knight up here to e5 and
then Bishop to f5 since it's no longer
attacking the bishop decides let's go
ahead and support this night here on e4
and then we see pawn to d4 getting ready
to push forward pawns who c5 this she
also has the opportunity to just start
exchanging in the center of the board
but if he wants to really push on his
opponent's really make black have a
cramped position he could play this pawn
to c5 so he has some options depending
on how he wants to continue after pawn
to b4 now Knight to c7 and this is the
spot where vichy nonsense is something
that this knight on e6 was kind of
hanging out didn't have to move right
now in the chignon is putting a lot of
pressure in there sent aboard and so he
took a lot of time on this move we see
27 minutes from mission on where all the
other moves he's playing in
five to ten seconds very very quickly
buddy he spent a lot of time to figure
out how he wanted to continue in this
spot and he played pawn to f3 says yes
that I'm gonna weaken my king side by
playing this but I really want to attack
and see what we can do with this efore
square Fabiano continues with Bishop to
g6 and this does look a little odd if
you're surveying the board here because
pawn just came up here to f3 to attack
this Knight you would almost assume that
this night is going to move but he
doesn't miss your back here to g6 after
only a few secs and Fabiano does not
take that night here he plays pawn up
here to c5 continuing with this plan if
you're curious why because vision on
didn't even take a lot of time in this
pawn to f5 move both these players very
familiar with the idea of if the pawn
takes here on e4 then the bishop takes
on e5 pawn takes at that Bishop we see
the pawn take here on e4 you can see
this opening up the door for the Queen
to attack here let's say the bishop
takes Queen down here to d4 and this is
a check also attacking this rook here on
a1 this would end up being extremely bad
for white so if we kind of look at this
and say yeah this looks fairly easy
let's go ahead and take that material
you have to a little dig a little bit
deeper both sides have been very
prepared for this so in this game vision
on doesn't think too long about it in
place pawn to c5 black decides let's go
ahead and take that night here on e5 we
see the pawn recapture then the knight
comes up here to g5 and this is the
first spot where Fabiano took time up
until this point you could tell that it
was rapid fire he wasn't thinking every
move was 5 to 6 seconds for this move
right here Knight to g5 he spent 27
minutes which is BA way beyond anything
that he had taken close to in this game
so far he had a few options he could
have tried a pawn to a5 he could have
said yeah let's go ahead and hang out
here
with this night right here and play
Knight to c6 he had some options but
decided too much pressure on the stern
of the board I'm gonna go ahead and give
up the control I had and play Knight
over here to g5 machine on plays Bishop
to b2 so doing a job of getting all of
his pieces directed his opponent he has
the Bishop parrots and open board States
his Queen and Bishop have a pretty good
combo here that if this Bishop were to
move he can start to attack the King
side even more the only thing he really
needs to do is get his knight involved
into the game right now it's not doing
too much on board now black plays pawn
to d4 which does disrupt a little bit
for what Vichy was trying to do it stops
the knight coming here to c3 getting
that vault into the game but blacks
gonna have to spend some energy some
pieces defending this square here on a
d4 he doesn't have any pawns that can
easily do that so vision Ana's a couple
options he could play Knight to d2 start
to give that involved into the game he
has a few options after he comes to d2
or you could play pawn to f4 and attack
the knight here on a g5 he's already
moved up his pawn so it doesn't really
matter too much if he continues to
extend it he's weakened his King side
just a little bit he decides to go for
the ladder he sees a strong attack here
with pawn to f5 and Fabiano sort of has
he's done the rest of the game he's
looked at these attacks on his minor
pieces and finds these small little
windows where he says I'm okay with you
taking that material because I have a
continuation that I'm prepared for and I
want to continue with so Knight to d5
and this point this Shaitaan says yeah
I'm gonna go ahead and take that he
didn't see a situation where it was
gonna end up biting him where earlier he
was gonna lose that work here on a1
didn't see that there is definitely
going to be an exchange but in the end
of the day this Shion on was okay with
it it all starts with the knight coming
down here to e3 this is attacking both
the Queen and the rook here on f1 we see
white play Queen to d2 does not want to
lose his queen as you can imagine that
Bishop comes down here takes here on
d 3 the queen takes now the night's
gonna take on f1 and after the king
takes we see a nice little exchange from
both sides vision on is comfortable
playing with a rook in two minor pieces
and Fabiano on the other side of the
board feels like he has a good pawn
structure and he's okay with his three
major pieces now the Queen comes down
here to g5 I like to take a minute and
just see and Vishy Anand position how
you would continue he has a lot of
options that he can go into play here he
could get his knight involvement to the
game hasn't played his knight anywhere
yet and all of a sudden this queen is no
longer defending this square here on d4
has a couple options could take it with
his Bishop could take it with its Queen
he could try to get some King safety
because the Queen can always come and
check the King here so what would you do
if you were in White's position now if
you chose one of the options of take
this pawn
probably not going to get the results
that you would have hoped for
if the bishop takes here on a d4 then
Queen to f4 check Bishop down here f2
potentially rook to a d8 attacking the
Queen and then Queen takes here on e5
attacking both the rook here on a1 and
this pawn on h2 probably want to stop
the rook from following maybe Knight to
c3 and then Queen down here to h2 if we
come back and say well the bishop
doesn't have to come to f2 absolutely
right King could come up here to e2 now
rook to d8 things get difficult for
white because both the rook and the
Queen are both attacking on the square
right here and the bishop can't move
because then the Queen would fall so no
great move that white has here going to
end up losing material now we come back
and say what if the Queen takes ok Queen
takes here on a d4 rook to d8 is the key
move here no great way for white to can
donate well let's say Queen to e4 now
rook down d1 check King up here to f2
Queen up here to g6 is interesting if
there is a trade maybe Queen takes pawn
recaptures this is a discovered attack
now the rook is attacking the King King
up here to e3
rook down f1 going to be very very
difficult for white
to hold on to this if the Queen does not
take if he decides to try something else
maybe Knight to c3 let's hold on to that
Queen I don't want to do the exchange
that was very very bad
okay now work up here to d2 Kings gonna
move and the bishop is going to fall
that's not a good option as well Queen
doesn't have to come to e4 let's say if
he tries Queen to c3 rook down to d1
check King up to f2 another check from
black rook to d8 it gets very very
difficult for white to hold on to this
position he's gonna just have to start
throwing pieces in front of it at the
end of the day he is going to lose so
efficient on very wisely decided there's
something up with the Queen coming down
here to g5 it's a very aggressive attack
and I don't just think you're gonna give
up this pawn here on d4 for nothing so
he decides to continue with Knight to d2
Queen takes here on e5 and then vichy
plays Knight to f3 great central control
from vision on he's gonna be able to
take this pawn here on a d4 and this
does threaten the Queen so it does need
to move Queen back here to h5 and then
the Queen can freely take here on a d4
so white comes out with the exchange he
was looking for still maintains control
of the board
black has three major pieces but they're
not really tied together with any sort
of threat the Queen over here at h5
can't do much by himself King beside
safety but that only gets you so far the
two rooks really need to get in the
suing the board start attacking their
opponents right now Fabiano playing
somewhat of a defensive game and just
hoping that he can find a strong attack
from his Queen plays pawn to f6 this was
a mating threat that he has to stop
queen up here to g7 if you're wondering
why he even played pawn to f6 didn't
want to stop the the mate and one Queen
over here to c4 check King over to h8
getting in safety bishop down here to c1
preparing for the bishop to come up here
to d6 this would be a great outpost now
that he
can see that the bishop here on b2 isn't
doing as much doesn't have the same
threat that he had before wants to find
the best position for it he's not gonna
be doing that by playing Bishop to d4
what does that really do wants to get
into a very very attacking square here
d6 does that cuts off a lot of squares
that black can go to and there's no
great way for black to really stop that
he doesn't have a minor piece whether it
be a bishop or a night and no pawns
gonna be able to stop that so that's
gonna be a critical square that black
can't avoid that Bishop coming to so
Bishop down here to see one rook to e8
Bishop to f4 as we talked about town
over here to a5 Bishop to a d6 so not
gonna get in way of vicious plan doesn't
really matter what Fabiana is trying to
do the pawn takes and the queen
recapture is gonna be extremely bad if
the pawn takes rook comes down here to
a1 check don't want to lose your rook
for nothing so decides to go ahead and
take the Queen with this Queen here on
before doesn't have to worry too much
about his pawn having a protection
because he does have this bishop here on
d6 protecting it Fabiana plays Queen to
a d5 it's a nice little outpost in the
center of the board gonna be a little
tricky right now for white to kick that
off right now so it does control a lot
but will need to get some of his rooks
involved into the game Queen takes here
on a b7 so it doesn't have to worry
about this pawn coming to let's say b6
and try to disrupt this nice thing going
that it has here on a c5 and d6 pawn to
h6 opening up the door for his King to
come to h7 if he ever needs to king over
here to g1
I wants to make sure that his opponent
can't get a cheap check in so the the
Queen down here to d3 would be
problematic but now really the only
square would be Queen to d4 which is
defended by the night here on f3 so
wants to make sure that he has safety
and then he can continue with any plan
that he has worked down here to a force
of Fabiano recognizing what he needs to
do and that is be aggressive rook to a4
pawn to h3 a rook over here to c4
to get an attack going a queen down here
to be to trying to hold down the fort he
sees he has a good thing going over here
so just trying to maneuver his Queen to
a very very good position was he queen
come down here to d3 rook to a2 just
doubling up he thinks he has pretty good
protection with his king can always come
up here to h2 g3 if he needs to Queen
down here to d1 King H - yeah that's
exactly we were expecting to see rook
down here to see one start in the attack
you know what are we really gonna do
from here it's not exactly sure how
you're gonna continue if you had another
rook okay that's an option here or if
you had something on let's say h4 that
could be good as well the knight would
potentially have to take that you could
start to have some attacking going on
but you allow right now your opponent to
just get his King involved into the
center of the board and you don't have
enough pieces to really continue when
it's Haqq we see pawn to a4 from mission
on and then pawn to f5 and f5 is an
interesting move I think he had some
better options here I think with pawn to
f5 and then pushing forward to f4
because he wants to control the square
here on a g3 so you know Queen over here
- h1 that's better I think it's probably
better if he tries the approach on the
Kings side of the board I do recognize
the knight could take this here but this
does open up the door the night on h4 is
much worse than on f3 where it is a very
very good Square from here but decided
to go and play pawn to f5 now Queen up
here - b7 starting a potential attack on
at the King side of the board f4 and
then the bishop just takes I think he
gave up some free material right here
rook takes here on a c5 so it tries to
blow up that outpost that white had
going good thing says I don't want to
have to worry about that anymore I'll go
ahead and give up my F pawn in exchange
for a new passport for Fabiana to
actually push this pawn but he was able
to get rid of that outpost now rook over
here
2d2 attacking the Queen Queen takes the
material here on a 4 and then we see
vichy played Queen to f7 very very
aggressive move from fishing on really
aligning his pieces up starting to get a
big attack putting a lot of pressure on
his opponent Fabiana decides it is now
time to play some defense plays rook to
g8 Bishop e5 and now pinning this pawn
down to the king not a lot of great
options that black has over here he's
gonna have to come out of this Jam with
his other Queen and rook here we see the
Queen come to see for threatening the
Queen and says yeah this is a bad piece
let's just go and exchange on board and
then vision on doing what vision on does
best this he finds an incredible move a
move that a lot of the players at the
tournament tweeted about afterwards
because it was so good I'd say take a
minute pause the video and see if you
could find the best move that machine on
ship played spoiler alert he found it
because he's the king and vision on
played rook to d6 and after this Fabiano
resigned there was no really way for him
to continue you can see what he's
threatening rook to h6 and that is made
even if the Queen takes here yeah take
my queen it's going to be mate the pawn
can't recapture because it's being
pinned down by the bishop if you were to
try something else let's say Queen to h4
okay well you can see how terrible that
is the Knights just gonna take here on
h4 if it says let's try to protect that
but we don't want to have to worry about
this Knight Queen down here to see one
well this has its own difficulties we
have rook up here to d8 this is
preparing Queen to g8 no great way to
stop this if you know if we see the rook
move okay well then just Queen takes
here on a g7 that's gonna be mate as
well so many options that black has to
worry about maybe instead okay let's
take this Rokinon a5 don't forget the
Queen came over here c4 initially to
attack this Queen the Queen is still
there
y can easily take that still threatening
a lot of options here and so okay the
rooks under fire he's gonna have to move
this could be a very easy in game for
Vichy and on
I think they've issued on walks away
with the victory playing against an
opponent that seems to have the petrov
on his mind he's been prepping for this
and Vichy and on played phenomenally I
don't really see any moves that he could
have done better at there was a lot of
tracks to Tommy on Oh tried to get him
in every single time machine on found
the correct way to continue he had a
specific game plan he went through that
and at the other day he found not easy
move at all to win it put the cherry on
top so congratulations to mission on
love how he prepares for tournaments
always seems like he comes in and
crushes these when he wants to so he is
doing extremely well a tied at the top
of the leaderboard Fabiano does fall a
little bit knowing that didn't pick up
any points today but thank you guys so
much for watching
in round 3 of the Tata Steel turnin
we've had some great games so far and we
have 9 rounds left so thanks everyone
I'll see you in the next video